the golden knights have one of the best
players
on the ice this week and they're getting
ready to play hockey on a golf course
talking about this and much more it's
time to face off with derek england
all right brian boyd it's great to kick
off another week as we face off with
derek
welcome back derek appreciate you being
here of course the knights one of the
top teams now
top team in the west playing really well
today marc-andre fleury was named
nhl's two-star player of the week i'll
tell you what this guy
all the trade rumors all that off-season
stuff he's one of the best players in
the league right now
definitely the way he's playing is uh
he's lights out he's been their best
player i think
uh hands down um and you know
all that stuff during the summer i think
give him a little fuel and
and he wants to come out and prove
himself and he's he's doing just that
he's
he's playing on top of his game right
now the best i've ever seen him play and
i think it's his you know playing with
him you see that competitive edge that
he has and it's
not only in games it's every day in
practice he doesn't want you to score
and
it's just carrying over to the games
he's uh so fun to watch
he battles for every puck there's never
one that he's out and
you know it makes it exciting to watch
and you mentioned it too he's such an
athlete i mean he's a great hockey
player great goalie
but he's not he's an athlete yeah he's
he's uh
so explosive he's so uh powerful in his
pushes and stuff
it's it's it's crazy to see him in the
gym he works so hard on and off the ice
and
it's paying off right now all right so
the series with the abs certainly a big
one we saw the the first of four with
this team the avalanche and the knights
was last night
impressed with vegas's play on nathan
mckinnon here's the guy who is just
awesome 45 shots on goal but last night
in about 22 minutes of play just four
shots on goal what are the knights doing
defensively that's kind of shutting
shutting this team down i think they're
staying right on top of them taking the
speed away
when one one guy gets beat there's
another guy right there to pressure him
so they're not giving that time and
space to
wind it up and get that speed and you
know
we're defending them in layers so it's
uh it's a guy that's
extremely hard to to check and they're
doing a great job the first game
knew when you think about too the vegas
golden knights they played thursday then
they played again on saturday and again
sunday uh they play again tomorrow
everybody really with this truncated
season is playing lots of games
but boy how mentally and physically
tough must this be
yeah it's a grind it's um you know that
uh the first game it's uh
you're all good for but that second one
and then you go to back to back and
um guys are feeling it especially a guy
like me getting uh getting older
something like that it was a it was a
wear on you but uh
you know it's all about rest and uh
getting eaten good and
just preparing yourself for that next
night and you know you just gotta
simplify the game and uh
make it easy on you all right you know
since you started playing hockey derrick
let me ask you how
often have you played on an outdoor rink
i bring that up because the vegas golden
knights in colorado play
on a golf course fairway this saturday
yeah i grew up on a lake
out on the lake so we just shovel a big
patch off and go play out there it was a
lot of fun you know you you'd start a
fire out there on the ice and
have some hot chocolate roast some hot
dogs marshmallows whatever you wanted
and
just have hockey games out there and it
was a lot of fun it brings back a lot of
good memories and i was fortunate enough
to play in two outdoor games with
pittsburgh so
it's a lot of fun it's it's a experience
that you'll never forget and
i'm interested to see how this one goes
you know amazed how many players have
not been to lake tahoe from this
golden knights team yeah it's amazing up
there i've been up there one twice
twice now and it's uh every time you
find something new that's
spectacular all right well derek thank
you once again for facing off with us as
we roll into a new week have a great
week we'll see you back here
next monday thank you